the father of a missing Iowa college
student believes his daughter may have
left willingly with someone she knows 20
year-old Molly Tibbets was last seen
taking her daily jog nearly three weeks
ago
Crimestoppers says it's received about
500 leads in the case
Adriana Diaz is in Brooklyn Iowa where
she spoke with Timothy's parents Adriana
good morning good morning this printshop
is the nerve center in the community's
effort to find Molly Tibbets they've
made thousands of items including
buttons posters and t-shirts her parents
told us that these images give them
comfort because they're in love with
their daughter's smile the FBI agent
called us and she told me I don't want
you to hear this on the news Molly
Tibbets parents got the phone call
Sunday they'd been dreading
investigators found a body but they
couldn't yet confirm if it was their
daughter what was your reaction terror
investigators soon announced the body
was not Tibbets but 20 year old Sadie
Alvarado who was found on the side of a
road in Lee County Iowa we immediately
when we found out thought about that
family and the tragedy that they went
through and in this in no way diminishes
their pain is there anything you want to
say to her family or the people looking
for her that is hopefully find her Wayne
Chaney who lives near the search area
says he's been questioned by
investigators at least five times about
Tibbets the farmer has several
convictions including stalking and
harassment charges and seven other cases
have been dismissed well there was an
FBI guy who he was just here not too
long ago this morning yeah what did he
ask you want me to do a polygraph chest
or something and I said no I'm not doing
it what do you think happened what do I
think is totally speculation I think
someone went to the house that Molly
knew or that Molly trusted and she left
with them willingly and now they're in
over their head and they don't know what
to do
Tibbits is one of more than 88,000
active missing-persons cases in the u.s.
her search continues to make national
headlines and billboards what do you
make of the outpouring of support from
coast to coast I think it's because
people see in Molly their own dog
their own girlfriend that her own sister
I think it struck a chord with people
that you know this could be happening to
me right now to my family Molly is more
than Robert Tibbets daughter at his
wedding earlier this year she was his
best man if she's watching this what do
you want to say to her
just hang on by we're gonna come get you
everybody's looking we also spoke to
Molly's boyfriend who says she is a
fighter and he believes she's still
alive police still haven't made any
arrests or named any suspects and the
reward is now more than two hundred and
seventy-seven thousand dollars Vlad Wow
all of us holding out hope yeah I was
hoping that she is okay yeah the dad is
right where he says everybody's looking
for you and as a family you just have to
hold out hope until you have news that
says you it tells you something one way
or the other but everybody's hoping that
other body that they found I was curious
so there were two women who were missing
out turns out she apparently had a fight
with her boyfriend jumped out of the car
and now that's a totally separate case
that's under investigation
scary yes indeed Adriana Diaz thank you
so much for that reporting